hey guys I wanted to make a video that's
a little out of the norm from what I
usually do this is in relation to these
Stoneman Douglas shootings and first and
foremost I have to say that I'm
incredibly proud of the way the kids
have been handling themselves how
they've been demonstrating all across
the country in the organization of
marches and talks with people in
political spheres and usually I stay out
of anything that has to do with politics
or religion or anything of the above but
in this particular case I felt I needed
to say something because some of my fans
have been affected by this and some of
my fans are out there demonstrating
about this and I wanted to say something
because I don't feel it's right that
kids have to be the ones on the
frontlines of this fight and and I
wanted to throw in my support and give
my thoughts on the matter for whatever
that may be worth but to give you a
background I have an extensive
background and experience with guns
my father was a 24-year Army man he was
a member of the NRA he taught me about
guns from a very early age and he taught
me to respect them and how to properly
handle guns I have gone to the shooting
range many times I've shot all kinds of
guns my dad even built muzzle loader
rifles as a hobby so when I say these
things just know that it's not coming
from a place of ignorance and first and
foremost I want to say that I don't
think people should be able to access
assault rifles there's no beating around
the bush there's no kidding about it
there's no exaggerations assault rifles
exist solely to kill people and you
could say the same thing about all guns
but assault rifles are especially they
don't have any purpose in hunting they
have a purpose in self-defense only to
the point where they can
till multiple people with a lot of
bullets in a very large magazine and I
know I'm going out on a limb into saying
this outright but I'm a hundred percent
in the field that we need to ban assault
rifles and I know that people will say
that gun control laws are not the thing
that can change this or at least they'll
say that it's not the only thing that
can change this but in my mind why not
do everything in our power to try to
protect our kids or our people or our
fellow countrymen or our neighbors and
in the avenue of trying to attack this
from both sides why don't we stop
stigmatizing mental health why don't we
stop treating it like some sort of
problem that people just need to bear
alone that should be the first and
foremost of everything not just in these
but in general because there's so many
people out there suffering silently with
mental illnesses that need help and are
so afraid to go out and get it because
of the way we treated in this country
and also why do we require more
licensing and registration for cars than
we do for guns I know that people abide
very closely by the Second Amendment and
me as a proud American I'm very proud of
our Constitution but at the same time
there has to be some measure of control
I know that people want to be able to
bear arms and I respect that I come from
a family that was all about that but
that doesn't mean that we can't have
some measure of control over these
extremely dangerous tools in the end
people will say that I'm spouting
ignorance or that I don't know what I'm
talking about
or that I'm saying things that are wrong
and that is fine but right now the only
thing that I can think of is why
shouldn't we be doing absolutely
everything in our power to help now is
not the time for talk now is not the
time for empty promises now is the time
to do something for the people that are
suffering most from this
and I want to end this by saying that
these kids that are out demonstrating
they are an inspiration an absolute
inspiration not just to me but to
everybody watching across the country
and if you're watching this and you are
out there demonstrating or you're
organizing marches or you're talking to
the people who are supposedly in power
of these decisions keep it up
cuz the world is listening the country
is listening people will try to ignore
you and people will try to dismiss your
opinion but you are the future of this
country and you are the future of the
world and your actions dictate what our
future will be so don't give up the
fight stay strong and thanks for
watching bye